okay guys I think I'm about to hit a
million subscribers on YouTube so I'm
gonna go around asking what my family
thinks of me hitting a million
subscribers on YouTube and maybe a
couple other questions hi dad also
um some of my siblings are gone so this
is just people that are here
a million subscribers on you
and you scrappers
uh
okay good the divorce rate is at roughly
50 people are getting married less and
less and less nowadays yeah very sad
what is the solution that would bring
men and women together I think have more
kids
laughs
what's funny just because that was
grandma because every question you asked
her
so is that your final answer have more
children no that is
um I would say everybody serving the
gender roles that God made them for
good answer Mom I would say okay next
question okay Do You Believe In Love of
course and his love of choice I think
staying in love is a choice so who you
fall in love with isn't a choice I think
it's the combination of personality and
opportunity you have to be open to this
situation in order for you to want to to
fall in love and then you have to have
feelings for that person so I think
there is something there's something
that's just there and then I think that
um combining that with
opportunity and being open to the
opportunity what type of guy would you
want me and Gabrielle over here to marry
oh I think one that loves you more than
they love them themselves one that is a
protector and a Defender one that takes
seriously his role as
the I guess the protector and the
defender in the family someone who works
hard someone who's fun someone I would
say a traditional man that's what I
would like for my for my son-in-laws to
be look how wifey mom is I'm serving tea
to the uh guests in my office that is
literally so cute it is so cute
definitely you've got so far this is so
stinking cute it is like a fire pot
though I don't know what the hell's
wrong with the people who invented it
they like want to kill you with being
hot mom's a swearer this is where we got
our potty mouths from
Chinese oh my gosh that's my New Year's
resolution
I made a spreadsheet okay
Baseline for my son-in-law is that he
first loves Jesus okay that's number one
Gabriel relationships are in the [ __ ]
okay divorce rates High people aren't
getting married anymore what
as a young woman going into the world
what's your solution speaking as a 20
year old yeah I mean obviously we're not
we're not we're not expecting good
Solutions here we're just gonna
everyone's gonna give their take
I feel like it's honesty because I feel
like a lot of times in the dating world
nowadays people are not upfront about
what they actually want or people are
like lie to themselves a lot like I feel
like like a lot of women will be like oh
well like he construed me this but then
she's like won't actually like
actually say like oh well I asked him
for this and I told him I wanted this I
feel like a lot of people just ignore
those hard conversations like men and
women not women specifically but I just
feel like those conversations are had so
I would say honesty because I feel like
nobody wants to say the uncomfortable
truth I think we love the uncomfortable
truth on the channel so so second second
what kind of guy would you like to see
me marry
um that's a good question Anna okay
um
you had you had your opportunity you had
I just forgot I really want a lot of
grandkids okay so a lot so mama I want a
lot of kids too so every man needs to
love kids a lot okay okay we'll make D1
athletes at our house okay
that's true we have we are prime
breeding stock
look at like Are We Wrong
okay okay so what kind of guy would I
want Hannah to marry
um someone who is very
um what did you say mom what are you
doing okay what is Mom what are you
doing that's entertaining
there could only be one Entertainer
I feel like someone who can keep up with
her because I feel like with you because
I feel like I feel like like even me
personally I know him a lot and being as
you're my sister you share a lot of
similar characteristics you are a lot
Hannah so I feel like somebody who can
kind of like Encompass all of that and
kind of almost like organize you in such
a way because I feel like you're every
direction oh my gosh I would love I
would love an organized man A Creative
free spirit and I feel like sometimes
you need a little Direction and like
boundaries per se for yourself does that
make sense and so it's like kind of like
an organized organizer
um a kind of man I want you to marry
somebody's organized somebody who can
kind of like direct your chaos and like
a more like formatted way uh because
like seeing as I'm very organized you're
an organization drives me mad
um yeah I would say someone who's very
organized somebody who
um somebody who can plan things very
well yeah bro I was very frustrated with
the lack of organization she's like
please please God have some social
medias what social media is kind of like
oh so somebody's hip kind of trying to
keep you what about the kids can we have
them a lot of kids for Mom if you want a
lot of kids I'm on like four if you
somebody who wants all the kids somebody
who makes you happy at the end of the
day I just want somebody who makes you
happy
oh do you believe in do you believe in
love and this love of choice
I think that you can love a lot of
different people in your lifetime and
you're bound to I think I would find
something in everyone to love whether or
not I actually like them yeah I think
that love I think a decision to love is
a choice I think kind of similar to what
Mom said is that like staying in love is
not like something that like is
initially a choice I guess initially it
is not a choice but over time it is a
choice because it's not something that's
like consistently like when somebody
gets old and fat you're not gonna love
them as much by like appearance per se
so I think love is a choice yes Mom so
Dad the divorce rate is at 45 the
marriage rate like getting married is
lower than ever what is the solution to
get men and women back together
I guess more time together more time
together
solve everything
do you believe in love yes or no do you
believe in love and it's too complicated
for
you believe in love I think it's real
but it's not a fixable
um yeah okay wow no no that's still I
don't actually know I'll say sure yeah
yeah all right do you guys think love is
a choice yes or no yes yeah
okay do you guys why do you
think people don't get married as much
anymore because being the one is better
being alone is better you think okay
Daddy Issues daddy issue
why do you think people don't get
married as much because we did it like
you said because love is a choice so
then they don't want to choose to stay
in love but just quit yeah so we got a
generation of quitters huh
dad do you believe in love of course
because I say no I'll be in deep trouble
so I think it's more of a gained and
mutual respect do you think Love's a
choice there's a difference between love
and lust oh guy shows guys it's a it's
an attitude let's see how you feel about
somebody is not it's it's something you
over time I think you get to understand
it's not something that comes naturally
or quickly I think lust comes instantly
but this is different what type of guy
would you want me to marry you said one
question okay I have another question
what type of guy would you want me to
marry one that you are happy with you
can be friends with and you could go
live a long life with
hey Adam um what do you think of me
hitting a million subscribers on YouTube
you know what YouTube is
it's more fun to teach you no answer
what do you think okay do you remember
when I was next door filming tick tocks
yeah
shut up
you remember you saw the come up right
remember when I was I was doing the mics
and trying to figure them out yeah yeah
yeah what do you think what do you think
of me hitting a million Subs that's
pretty cool I know pretty cool it's
pretty cool don't get into knowledge
what do you mean you're on it before I
know yeah do you remember when I was
making tick tocks around the house Ice
Cream Sandwich as a reward
um no I would like I I would like you to
be my servant for a day
and I'd like you to call me Your
Highness
um what do you guys think of me hitting
a million subscribers on YouTube
congrats nice work thanks guys did you
hit it no not yet but I'm about to
what do you do you guys remember when I
was running around the house filming
tick tocks like I know yeah okay do you
remember when I was doing it more often
yeah like when you would like be around
a corner and I'd be just like walked
with my laundry basket
they were funny they were we gotta we
gotta bring that back family vlogs all
right next we're the children not in
here
Eva
all right guys guys could you guys pause
it for one second one second I'm about
to win game okay
okay one happy birthday Amelia thank you
close
um two what do you guys think of me
about to hit a million subscribers on
YouTube iconic iconic yeah good job good
job Amelia will you stop getting tattoos
I'm getting one in two days
are you have you ever watched a stream
no
you watched one
yeah
have you watched one of my streams no
okay I started are you gonna get tattoos
I don't know say no say no Haram no no
she won't you always already told me yes
all right I can't I can't save them all
guys what do you guys think of me
hitting a million subscribers on YouTube
wait would you say that again say that
say that again
say that again
did you call me a loser
all right guys it wasn't even a year ago
that I started the show the pregame on
my channel just pearly things and it was
February 27th so it hasn't even been a
year and it's crazy because we just got
to a million subscribers in a year
um I first wanted to say thank you I
question every day what I've done to
deserve such an honor of being able to
entertain you guys I absolutely love
what I do so I appreciate it it's so
crazy because last year I was sad I was
fat I bad aced me I just got on
relationship and I just needed something
to distract myself so I was like you
know what I'm gonna make this show and I
had so much fun I made so many friends
through the show I've learned so much
about men about women
um I've even learned about all you know
the disadvantages that men face today
and it's crazy because in the past year
my life has completely changed so oh I
wanted to thank each and every one of
you for subscribing for following and
let me know in the comments what you
guys want to see next I love you guys so
much bye